¿Usted sabe que el mundo sigue su ritmo?
¿Importa que yo quiera morir? Morió mi papá.
Y a mí me salvó que no es un facto que yo estoy aquí.
Que fui salvado.
¿Qué pasó después con ustedes?
Con nosotros pasó así.
El hermano mayor era un hombre muy débil.
¿Cómo se llamaba?
Pínjas.
Raíz.
Sobol.
Nombre de papá, nombre de mamá.
¿Por qué era débil?
Usted solo puede entender
cuando unos padres aquí en Venezuela
no pueden dar comida a sus hijos.
No tienen.
Están creciendo.
Están debilitados.
Otro hermano mío
agarró un tífus
y se quedó
morir.
¿Qué hermano fue ese?
Hérchan.
Tercero hermano mío, Einar,
tenía más fuerza.
El cuatro mío, Gedal,
era de la altura que usted ve,
meia malta, a esa altura.
Era una persona que no importaba nada.
No es muy agradable decir cómo era mi hermano,
si usted me entiende.
No tengo que declarar la verdad como era.
¿Y ustedes se quedaron?
Ya están.
¿Se quedaron en...?
En otro mundo, todos.
Entonces,
mi mamá
tenía escondido
una cadera de oro
como antes los novios regalaron,
regalan a los novios,
no como caderas.
Hoy, mire, cadera es bastante larga
y tenía escondido.
En ciudad
vino un señor,
se mudó de un pueblo
para Hualdaba.
¿Ustedes regresaron a Hualdaba?
Sí.
Y
tenía poquito plata.
Entonces, mi mamá
estaba casada, él,
con una prima mía,
como usted tiene notada,
una hija de mi tío Isser,
Leipzig Eiber.
Y él dio su cadera
que presta algo de dinero.
Se hizo algunas cosas
y no fue muy bien.
Los años corren
y ahora muchachitos muy ambiciosos.
En este pueblo
británico
era, vivía otro gran hacendado,
se llamaba Karpinsky.
En 1918
mataron a él,
se quedó un solo hijo.
Tenía una riqueza incalculable,
bosques,
campos, terrenos,
mejores terrenos del mundo
para pan blanco que saben
o hay campo para pan negro,
para Polonia,
diferente de clase de tierra.
Yo no sé,
lo estoy haciendo una mezcla, ¿no?
Ese Karpinsky
tenía un hogar en caballos.
Entonces él debía mucho venderlo.
Entonces quisieron embargar a él.
Se juntaron
36 socios,
Warsaw, Lubin, Bialystok
y compraron toda riqueza
en ese bosque.
36 socios.
Mi suegro
era un hijo
de un rabino,
Abraham Weinstock,
rabino,
ciudad Ojendof.
Mi suegro,
casado con la señora que usted tiene foto aquí,
no era comerciante.
¿Qué pasó?
Era hermana de mi suegro.
La esposa era socio de este país,
de 36 socios.
Y ya pusieron a mi suegro como administrador.
Y viajaba,
y ya pusieron en ese bosque
cerradera,
molino
y todo el trabajo.
¿Y usted ya era su suegro?
No, yo tenía
nueve años.
Yo estoy diciendo cómo la cosa
pasó nueve años.
Yo no sé,
esto no puede explicar
que yo logró
tener en mi poder
cinco eslotes.
Cinco eslotes,
cinco veinticinco era un dólar,
toda la vida en Polonia.
Como aquí era veinte y pico años,
cuatro veinte el dólar.
Y yo me fui para allá de él.
Una idea, ¿no?
Y dijo,
Pañe Váinstok,
un polaco,
yo quiero comprar
a mitad de un árbol de usted.
Se puso de irse.
Era un hombre muy mildo,
muy orgulloso.
¿Qué tú vas a hacer, mi hijo?
Vamos a ver.
Y yo agarró.
En fin, yo
agarró dos palacos.
Ya no era, mire,
antes cómo hacer buen polonio,
no era casas
de bloques,
no era bloque.
Había todos de madera,
cuatro pulgadas de greso,
así se hizo casas.
Tenían dos polacos,
Slonchik y Magdai,
ambos vinieron de Rusia,
sobrevivieron en Rusia la revolución.
Tenían dos palos,
arriba un palo y otro,
y se puso hasta arriba,
y se hizo tres
tablas de cuatro pulgadas.
A ella le gustaba mucho
tomar vodka.
Ahí aprendieron Rusia,
rusos gustan mucho vodka.
Me hicieron esto,
yo no sé cómo logró.
Pagó a ellos,
y yo vendí esto,
y ya ganó 15 lotes, ganó yo.
Te salgo.
Fantoya ya tenía
20 lotes en mi poder,
y era un rey.
¿Qué edad tenía usted?
Nueve años.
¿Y qué pasó con los estudios?
¿Cómo?
Conmigo.
Con los estudios,
el colegio.
Ya, listo,
ya pasó el colegio.
Parece yo que dijo usted,
la puerta a la puerta,
que es hombre muy pobre.
Tengo que declarar la cosa,
la verdad,
que yo no podía estudiar,
ya pasó, mire,
colegio de muchachos, mire,
y más,
yo no podía,
haber sufrimiento de mi mamá.
Hay un escritor,
conocido del mundo,
se llama Shulam As,
ya estaba todo el mundo,
cuando él pasó la revolución en Rusia,
atrás de él,
corriendo bolcheviques,
llegan a matar a él,
entonces él brinca en un techo arriba,
y dice,
a mí usted me va a agarrar,
y pasó,
y sobrevivió a la guerra.
Es un libro de 500 páginas,
se llama
Shulam As Mochkeganov,
ese todo el mundo conoce,
mire,
un gran escritor.
Pues ese,
leyendo,
yo leí mucho,
muchos escritores y libros.
Vamos a dejar eso.
Entonces empezó el negocio a los nueve años.
Usted sabe que después de la guerra,
llegó en poder,